más ambiciones que planes concretos
durante su primer discurso del año el
Primer Ministro británico Rich y sunat
presentó las prioridades de su gobierno
para 2023 reducir la inflación a la
mitad crear nuevos empleos aligerar la
deuda nacional mejorar el sistema de
salud y regular la migración ilegal
serán los puntos en los que sunat
aseguró concentrarse Durante este año
Esas son las prioridades del pueblo las
de su gobierno y las habremos cumplidos
sin trucos ni ambigüedades uno
trabajaremos por ustedes
luego de meses de inestabilidad política
y económica y la presencia de tres
primeros ministros en menos de un año la
economía sigue siendo la principal
preocupación de los británicos en
octubre de 2022 la inflación alcanzó su
punto más alto desde 1977 con un 16.4%
interanual superando a otros países
europeos y a Estados Unidos
la salud es otro punto álgido el cual ha
provocado oleadas de protestas exigiendo
la reducción de la lista de espera del
servicio de sanidad público y aumento
sustantivos de salario para los
trabajadores del sector en cuanto a la
migración sunat anticipó que su gobierno
aprobara nuevas leyes para frenar la
entrada de migrantes a través del Canal
de la Mancha y finalmente el también
economista llamó la atención con un
anuncio sobre cambios en la educación
ampliando la enseñanza de las
Matemáticas
sobre las huelgas hay mucha
desinformación quiero que la gente
entienda la posición del gobierno
valoramos enormemente a los trabajadores
del sector público como las enfermeras
es pidió ser juzgado por sus resultados
el premiere de 42 años Busca dar
confianza sobre su capacidad para
liderar a los conservadores hasta las
legislativas de 2024 elecciones en las
que los lauristas mantienen una amplia
ventaja a la fecha en las encuestas